[Music]
you're turning 16 next year I am are we
gonna see you getting behind a vehicle
anytime soon maybe I'm soon okay but
when I was 16 yes actually I have my
plan for my car I want to get a Tesla
with the ramp doors you know the little
flower yep and then he ain't gonna know
okay close it's gonna be wrapped in
rainbow sparkles and have a giant silver
retractable unicorn horn kids are they
gonna make it for you have you talked to
Alan how about this I'm gonna talk to it
well I could talk to Elon about it but
I'm gonna talk to West Coast Customs
about it yeah I have I hope today's
everyone's gonna be coming up to you
because they're gonna know what you're
quiet is that scary y'all I already
right now I have a red car and we called
the car little red literally at least
twice like every time we're in the car
people are like oh that's Joe Joe's car
like a will see them on like they'll
take pictures on it so it's cool but
yeah you know he's not gonna make it
yeah I mean let's recognize well when
are you gonna get your permit is that on
the bucket list for this year for this
year in Nebraska you can get your permit
at 15 and your leggings at 16 so
technically if I was home in Nebraska
then I could already be driving up you
have a permit I could have a school
permit by now to drive by myself but in
California I think is you can get your
permit at 15 and a half and then your
license at 16 okay but every day that
you wait after 15 and a half you have to
wait that many after you're 60 to get
your license yeah it's weird out here so
I'm thinking about just getting my
license in Omaha yes
so it's just less complicated but I'm at
the same time I'm like I'm a California
kid I want a California license we still
decided everything are your parents
nervous about that I don't know cuz the
thing is is you know I'm gonna get a car
I probably won't drive that often like
I'll probably drive the city walk and
then to set no bubble Georgia said but
on Friday I feel like city wide with my
brother and then I'll probably drive
home yeah
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]